IT WAS A MAIN TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION YESTERDAY BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
SAUDI ARABIA'S CROWN PRINCE.
THIS EVENING, CORRESPONDENT
GILLIAN TURNER TELLS US WHERE
THINGS STAND RIGHT NOW.
>> THE IRAN DEAL IS COMING UP.
>> AFTER MONTHS OF WILL HE-WON'T
HE RHETORIC OF THE NUCLEAR DEAL
IS ON THE PRESIDENT'S MIND ONCE
AGAIN THIS WEEK AS HE FACES A
MAY 12TH DEADLINE TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO RECERTIFY IT.
NOW POLICYMAKERS ARE ONCE AGAIN
ABUZZ ABOUT THE AGREEMENT'S
FUTURE AND THERE IS A GROWING
CONSENSUS THAT THIS TIME AROUND,
IT MAY FINALLY BE DAD ONCE AND
FOR ALL.
LEADERS ON CAPITOL HILL PREDICT
THE PRESIDENT OF BOTH OUT IN
COMING WEEKS, GIVEN THAT THE
U.S., BRITAIN, FRANCE, AND
GERMANY HAVE SO FAR FAILED TO
AGREE ON A PATH FORWARD.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT LIKELY
WILL MOVE AWAY FROM IT UNLESS
OUR EUROPEAN COUNTERPARTS REALLY
COME TOGETHER ON A FREE MARKET.
>> THE U.S., E.U., AND IRAN OR
CAN BE CONVENING IN VIENNA FOR
THE LATEST ROUND OF NEGOTIATIONS
IN THE U.S. WANTS ACTIONS ON A
LIST OF COMPLAINTS, INCLUDING
THE BALLISTIC MISSILE PROGRAM, A
LEDGER SUPPORT FOR TERRORISM,
ILLEGAL DETENTION OF AMERICAN
PRISONERS, EGREGIOUS HUMAN
RIGHTS RECORD, AND FIBER AND
MARITIME AGGRESSION.
THIS IS OTHER U.S. ALLIES FROM
THE MIDDLE EAST WING AND LOUDLY
HERE IN WASHINGTON.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE IRAN IS
BREAKING THE DEAL CURRENTLY?
>> I BELIEVE THAT THE IRANIANS
ARE DOING WHATEVER THEY CAN TO
TRY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH REGARDS
TO THE NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
>> ADMIN DIVISIONS OFFICIALS